health's of guys my name is a cello and
welcome to the next episode of the
series Asian series so last time we took
a look at how we could basically begin
writing this writer class right which
would handle all of our actual kind of
writing to a destination writing bias to
a destination and it also had some loose
information about our general file
format and whatnot and today we're going
to kind of extend on that add all the
data types together and actually start
coming up with a bit of a system as well
okay so let's let's get into that
without further ado I'm gonna try and
make these episodes a lot a lot snappier
because I kind of do want to get this
over and done with so we can get back to
multiplayer and game programming and
whatnot but yeah we'll see how we go
because obviously I want to be able to
explain all this stuff and I want you
guys to understand exactly what's going
on so so far we've got a way to write by
it's short since and long so these are
basically the four types of integer that
we have right the four integer integer
types that we have in in Java you could
also say the char is an integer type and
you could kind of deal with that but
byte is kind of I think actually I'm I'm
pretty sure I'm not even 100% sure I
think it's char in our in Java is
actually 2 bytes if I'm correct I'm
pretty sure I'm right and it's unsigned
I think isn't it so char a pulls let's
just try like 500 yeah 5,000 let's try
like 40,000 see that's okay
so I'm guessing 65535 is the last value
and 6 would give us now yeah so looks
like a char acts like an unsigned short
okay which is quite nice so I don't know
if we will bother doing that we might
you know what let's do it just because
it's going to be exactly the same so if
we wanted to have a child we would
simply well that's it actually we're
just done straight away okay so it's
very simple to do you could probably
just kind of deal with this as well but
it's probably better to make it make the
UM make a separate method for that so
there we go so we've got basically all
of the industry types implemented here
okay byte short char int and long
okay now the other big problem that we
have is dealing with decimal types
because a lot of people get really
confused for some reason with those okay
so decimal types being float and double
those are the two that we have available
to us in Java okay and then there's also
other types that we have to deal with
such as bullying and strings as well
which is another big one which we will
also cover but essentially the easy way
and the way that you Pro should probably
write bytes in in terms of if they're
floats or doubles is actually just
basically kind of read the data that
makes them up obviously and then handle
them like an integer so luckily for us
let's just write the prototype here so
probably that word right by its we've
got the byte destination we've got the
pointer and of course we've got the
actual value so the good thing that
exists here in java is actually in the
float class there is a function called
to float to int bits okay so it's an
interesting function it takes the floor
as the value right and essentially what
it spits out to us is let me just see if
I can attach the source code so we can
take a look at what it actually does
well we okay so you can see that
unfortunately it's going to be a native
yeah but essentially what it does and
again it's it's really is it is a bit of
a native operation because it has to
actually read the memory and see what
that returns but you can see that
essentially what it does is it takes in
a float and it spits out an integer
which just kind of is the bytes that
make up that float so we know that a
float is four bytes which means that
it's essentially a text to decimal
digits right and that number whatever
that is which represents that float it
will spit out back to us as an integer
okay of course a float in memory still
looks like say an integer in memory it's
just structured it a little bit
differently but what I mean is it still
like just four bytes of data essentially
and if we if we want to get those four
bytes of data we can do something like
float two n bits which is just really
simple really easy to do so um once we
do have that and I'll just call this
like dart
right it'd be interesting to actually
see what that data looks like again it's
just probably going to look like a very
high number so if we do something like
let's see if I just literally call right
bytes we don't even need destination
point or whatever but we are pleasantly
like 1.1 @f or something in here then
you can see that we get this number
which is just some random kind of high
looking number okay but what you need to
realize is that is simply B
representation of a float in memory okay
and that's all we need because if we
want to recreate it we can essentially
do the opposite of the thing so if we
take this number in fact I'm just going
to demonstrate this real quick if we
take this number real quick and we'll
we'll see what the opposite of this is
so I'm guessing that there's let's see
where is the so there's also an int
value which you can do if you caught the
float I guess we could have done that as
well but it's also int bits to float of
course right and it's actually the
native version of it but I'm sure
there's yeah in fact that that's it
right so what you can do are to recreate
this is of course if I did something
like this and I had to print line a new
sorry float dot int it's to flirt and I
pasted it in that number and I printed
that number of course and I'll even have
like a little flirt over here you can
see that we would get one point one okay
there we go so that's how it works very
simple I just wanted to make sure that I
was pretty thorough there with my
explanation so that you guys understand
what I'm doing and then of course it's
just an integer so what we could do is
simply return right by its destination
within desk pointer being pointer and
then value of course being data in this
case okay and we could just do something
as simple as that and that will work out
great so I don't know why I made this
avoid method let's just make it an int
method but there we go okay so we can do
something as simple as that and that
will work nicely for us double as you
can imagine is going to be the exact
same things that with a double so if I
just wrap double value here and I do
something like double dot
I'm guessing it's just going to be done
to end bits is that this probably going
to be too long bits because obviously it
needs to take off a five so I'm just
going to yes yep okay noloty yes
obviously this needs to return
sorry obviously this yeah this will just
work actually because of course we've
got a long version for that prototype
but there we go okay very simple stuff
again that double will do the exact same
thing is it'll work the same way as the
float does so that's done all right
now the final primitive type that we've
got I believe I haven't missed anything
everything I have is of course the
boolean so we'll have right bytes by its
destination and pointer double value now
this is a bit of a this is a bit of an
issue because we need to think about how
we actually want to sorry not double
volume saying stuff this thing correct
well we've got this issue here where a
boolean is essentially one byte okay
there's no reason for us to ever take up
more than one byte a bullying is
typically represented as 1 byte in
memory now you might be thinking to
yourselves why is that the case if
really it just takes up 1 bit right it's
gonna be either 0 or 1 that cannot be
represented by one bit and of course it
can but the issue is that memory can
only be addressed by bytes right you
can't address memory by bits bytes is
the lowest level of memory addressing
that you can get to okay so we can't
have we can't say fit eight bits
we can't just address eight bits into a
byte if that makes sense so you can't be
like when we actually go in like say say
that we make a variable called a or
whatever and just say that's somewhere
memory if we try to get to that and a
wife said it was five but let's say it's
false if we try and get to that it can't
be like bit number one point five or
something it has to be like a whole bite
right or bite number one point five
right it has to be a whole byte we can't
address memory more finally essentially
than bytes that's why they take out one
bite so essentially it's one bit with
seven bits of just padding which is just
going to be zero right
or even garbage doesn't really matter
but the idea is that's how it works of
course you can
yourself encode aid billions into a
single bite easily right all you have to
do is basically make a bit field which
is just essentially being like oh hey
you know if I I can fit let's just say
it I've got my you know bit field here
and it's equal to zero I can be like if
I had a bunch of bullying's in fact
let's do this experiment now why not
we're learning about this fun stuff here
so we'll continue on and and do
something cool so I'll clear all this
stuff so if we've got a bunch of boolean
so let's just say we've got an array of
boolean's aided them and then we'll just
literally go through them and we'll
maybe set them all to random values so a
I equals new random Dino this is
obviously not the best way to do it but
I'm just writing code no one cares
okay don't need to instantiate random
every time the doesn't matter it's fine
it's okay it's just a demonstration so
now that we've got eight random
bullying's we can actually put them into
the single bit field pretty easily okay
what we can do is we can actually go
through all eight billions here whoops
eyes on snare I plus plus and then we
can simply say that the bit field is
going to or equal one shifted left or so
not one it will be what is it a I
shifted left by the amount of spaces
that were opposite which is I okay and
if we do something like that it will
actually encode it for us now why is
this complaining why just going to say
off is a boolean okay well we can cause
it to an ant first how's that what oh
this is awful
all right so if it's true we'll say one
if it's false we'll say zero this is
rubbish all right there we go so we can
do something like this so let me quickly
just print let me quickly just print
that for example and we'll have
something like the reason I'm showing
you this by the way some is well because
you
knowledge but also be because we might
actually use something like this if we
wanted to store a raise of balloons for
example because it's obviously a lot
more efficient instead of taking 8 bytes
it takes one byte which is 8 times
smaller which is fantastic anyway we'll
print this first and then at the end we
will do we have a way to print so we can
print it in hexadecimal there's a way
Java to binary strings as a way in jail
and you just Google it's real quick to
actually convert an integer into a
binary string so integer to binary
string it actually what it is so then
we'll also print integer dot to binary
string and then integral to bit bit
field alright cool
there yeah so if we run this real quick
what you'll see is that if we start here
at the beginning we have true true true
true
we should these four bits two falses
false false and then two trues again and
if I keep running this or whatever okay
so this one's actually one true followed
by like seven leading zeros right em
anyway you can kind of see how that
works possible false and you can encode
that and of course you can do the
opposite to extract the values back so
it's really really simple to do
something like this
it's used a lot in you know data formats
and whatnot it's a good way to kind of
encode your bullying's into a single
four but okay so this integer is
actually i just relized four bytes but
if we just we can just change that to a
byte and it will obviously work the same
way
there you go let me just I don't know if
there's a byte dr. binary string which
is unfortunate anyway you can just get
rid of like the first few but you kind
of get the point right this will fit
into into a single byte so there we go
we've got about that that's cool fun
stuff when I've got to bother with that
for now especially because this is
supposed to be a very simple kind of
striation format I just wanted to show
you that so that you could implement
that yourselves kind of for homework or
if you just wanted to give it a shot or
do it in your own format that you can
definitely do something like that but
essentially for bullying's all we'll do
is again it's just really really simple
we'll just do some
thing like destination point of plus
plus equals value 1 or 0 so if value is
true we'll set that to 1 otherwise we'll
set it to 0 ok simple as that
now why is this complaining destination
is a byte
yeah wise is complaining conquer go from
n to pi well what if I take a beta does
that work pair not all right well that's
always fun
guess we're casting it to a by it all
right there we go done so and then we
can obviously return pointer okay and
then there we have our boolean obviously
it's a bit of a waste is gonna you know
leave the rest of the seven bits just
doing nothing but it works and it will
continue working for as long as we need
it so let's just said that's true and
this one to false and then we can
obviously print them and see what we get
so that's actually gonna I just realize
crash let's go back and not write this
long twice let's try it once and then
where are we
so these did we write along there that
does not look like how much space 16 hmm
is suspicious that's very suspicious
let's just get rid of this from true
for the minute yeah that's because wait
no that's fine let's see what this gives
us okay we've got 1 and 0 ok obviously
we made it 16 so that's why it's got so
much padding I'm not sure what I was
reading there though because that just
looked weird to me
let me quickly bring that back here so
we were doing the number which was the
minimum value whatever so we do that
first then so that's like but I just
don't see the one anymore oh well that
would be why let's do something like you
know some random number instead
all right so there's the one and then
that there's a zero and a human because
this is the first eight bytes right
there's our one the true there's our
false zero and then the rest of them are
just all set to zero because it's just
the remainder of the bytes okay
pretty cool stuff so that's how that
works very very simple if you guys have
any more questions you can leave them in
the comments below if you enjoyed my
videos and you can support me on patreon
comm four slash the channel if you do so
you will you can pick up some pretty
cool rewards such as getting access to
all together growing code by a private
github repository but even if you do
pledge a little bit of money then
obviously that helps me put out the
videos more often and generally just
supports the series and what I do so the
other thing that's pretty awesome is of
course the Cherno slash chat so you can
head over to select alternative comm
sign up and essentially you'll get added
to a kind of instant messaging kind of
community where you can talk about
people about various things including of
course what we just covered in this
video if you need any more help and
whatnot
that's a great place to get it and it's
kind of all real time messaging so
people will it apply to you instantly I
have it like on my phone so if you guys
are talking about something interesting
I I tend to chime in pretty often and
it's just a really good community it's a
really good place to be because I don't
really put out videos as often as I
would like and so because of that kind
of when there's this kind of radio
silence and I'm not putting out videos
you can always kind of go on that chat
ask me what's up and maybe have if you
guys have any questions you can ask me
there and it's just a really kind it's
just a really nice place to hang out in
between the videos right during the
intermission but anyway that is pretty
much how the cookie crumbles if you guys
enjoyed this video please hit like
button and I'll see you guys next time
so next time we're actually going to so
we've written pretty much everything we
have to write okay
I think next time we'll talk about how
we can write out strings because they're
the only kind of type that we don't
write out you guys might not realize it
but what we've got here there's kind of
ride bias with pretty much every data
type there is right this is actually
basically all the data we need okay
we're missing two kind of things but
they're not primitive
right we've covered every single
primitive data type we're missing
strings which costs aren't primitive
strings are essentially just a raise of
characters right but then we're also
missing just a raise in general so what
if we wanted to write out like I don't
know 10 integers right how do we do that
of course we could simply call this
method 10 times with all of our
different values but again that doesn't
particularly group them into an array we
need a way to basically write a header
into that array being like hey this is
how long the array is for example okay
but that's more to do with our actual
data structure that we choose for our
file format and we'll definitely talk
about that more next time but we're
gonna cover strings next time because
we'll have kind of a stand format for
writing out strings which should be
pretty awesome so anyway have fun do
this ask any questions in the comments
and I'll see you next time goodbye